I like the way they just I love the way
they sink in like that slowly go down
it's like quicksand
alright it's not affect this well you
don't know oh listen Vegas and some hey
are they gonna blow up in slow motion
just learn how random guess this racial
vignette film this paint on the sixty
and ten at 15,000 frames a second should
be priests should be slow enough to see
some glass going all over the place I
think so yeah
[Music]
good strategy faces like no [ __ ] though
finest
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so Dan oh yeah
slight modifications this time many sort
of makeshift holder nice order there
good order
it's a new order pop you drew that's
your favorite thing pop eager yeah no no
no Oh Rick your boy knows Ricky Bahl I
[Music]
like the fact that he's a true good boy
which reduce all that was truly awful I
was like think plastic pot root your
book by Bob
[Laughter]
right
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that was quite yeah I really liked how
the the paint exposing different way
dogs dinner the see that's a nice little
bit I've never seen the initial
explosion that's low there are 15,000
flames I mean usually a painless like
this slow down that was cool to see it
was interesting how so they extrude and
so he's went straight up yeah some of
rockets and there ah bloody nightmare
that only have him put this in the
washing media I've got hair my pack see
yeah oh let me see me shot
[Music]
oh that your camera oh my gosh oh ha ha
oh my gosh